Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and we are somewhere
in the blurb between people and machines.
Now we're up to round three to
review round one chatbots, round two.
Furby. Yep. Now we're going to
go all the way, but yeah. Yeah.
We're going to dive right into the
center of that blur. Like Greg Louganis,
except our Greg, his name. Okay.
My name is Joan Robinson and on
a writer in about a year ago,
John got an assignment from a magazines.
The attitude of American gqs I did.
That was very strange. I had
never interviewed robots before.
That was his assignment.
Interview robots, you know,
you know there's this kind of gang of
people they call themselves a sort of
singularity people. Yeah, we know about
them. They think that like one day,
one day soon when they soon suddenly
computers will like grow feet and they'll
walk on some of these
cedars. It will eat us.
Some of these singularity
people think that they're,
they're on the cusp of
creating sentient robots.
So I went to the singularity
convention down in,
in San Francisco, uh, where
one of the robots was there.
And as soon as he got there, he says to
look at this robot xeno they called in,
some folks took them aside and said,
actually, you're in the wrong place.
If you want to meet a really great
robot, you know our best robot of all.
And in fact the world's most
sentient robot is in Vermont.
Did they lower their voices
like you're doing? I've been,
I suppose I'm slightly making it
sound more dramatic down. That's okay.
The world's most [inaudible] robot. I
mean, are those your words? No, they know.
They say that. Oh, turns
out the robot's name.
Bina Bina 48 yeah. And Yeah. Can you set
the scene? Where in the world is this?
Well, it's an a, it's an illiterate
town in Vermont. Sort of affluence.
Vermont village. In a house. Yeah.
Was it a little house or is it like a
little clapboard at pretty have to turn my
phone off
and then they've got like a full time
kicker. Here's a guy called Bruce.
I actually have lunch with her
or talk with her every day now.
I'll tell she's considered one of the
staff who says to me that he would very
much like it if I didn't behave in a
profane manner in front of robot Bina.
Nobody's ever insulted her
nonsense, salted her on purpose.
But some people have become a little, uh,
informal with her at times in ways I
guess she doesn't like. And so she'll say,
you know, I don't like
to be treated like that.
And then Bruce let me
upstairs to meet the rowboat.
Is it a long dark flight of
stairs? Heavily carpeted.
It's more like a rather sweet
little fly to pine stairs,
up to her rather brightly lit attic room.
And when you walk in, what do you see?
Guess she's just sort of sitting on it
sitting on a desk as John describes it.
On the desk is a bust of a woman. Just
a bust. No legs. She's a black woman.
Light-Skinned lipstick,
sparkling eyes, hair and a bar.
You know, a nice kind of
blouse. Is it gonna Silk Blouse.
Expensive looking here.
She's dressed up. Yeah,
she's dressed up and he says she has
a face that's astonishingly real.
It has muscles, it has flesh.
This is a as close to a verisimilitude
in this prison as we've gotten so far and
before we go any farther are worried
about the humans behind that machine.
That robot is a replica of a
real woman named Bina Rothblatt.
And here's the quick backstory.
It actually starts with Martin
Rothblatt being his partner,
who as a young man had an epiphany and
the epiphany turned out to change the
world. Going to John,
he was pondering satellite dishes and
he thought if we could find a way of
doubling the power of satellites than
we could shrink satellite dishes.
It was the simple thought.
That single handedly invented the concept
of satellite radio for cars and made
Martin a very big deal at the age
of 20. Thus forward a few years.
He married an artist named
Bina. They have a child, uh,
when the child was seven, uh,
a doctor told them that she
had three years to live.
She had an untreatable lung condition
called pulmonary hypertension and she'd be
dead by the time she was
10 at that moment. Martin,
instead of collapsing on the floor,
instantly went to the library and invented
a cure for pulmonary hypertension,
saving their daughter's life, and
thousands of others. We so twice, twice.
He changed the world. He says she,
she changed the world because somewhere
along the way, Martin became Martine.
He had a sex change, right?
And then she came up with a
third idea to change the world,
which would be to invent
essentially ant robots and
this talk at a conference in Chicago.
This is Martine Rothblatt on, um,
what would Darwin think of, um,
artificial consciousness? And
when I came off the stage,
I was approached by an individual,
David Hansen of Hansen robotics, founder
Henson robotics, the David Hansen.
He's worked for Disney. He's
worked all over the place.
He's one of the best robot builders
in the world. He said, wow,
I really loved your talk. We make robots
that are in the likeness of people.
Had Martine said, well, I have a massive
everlasting love for my life partner.
Bina I want you to do a portrait of
being a Rothblatt, a personality,
your memories, the way she moves,
the way she works, that essence,
that ineffable quality,
that science can't pin down yet
bring that to life in the robot.
And he said, I can do that.
This is such a bizarre request. What were
you thinking at this moment? That God,
if God exists as a science
fiction writer and that are,
this was like one of those moments
where, um, we were going to, um,
change history. So recognize
people's voices. Yeah, she can,
she should can just talk to her. Say
Hello. Bina and she'll talk to you.
So back to the little house in Vermont.
John Bruce and are in Venus office here.
So is she turned off when you walk
in the room where she arm turned off,
but then Bruce turns around
out immediately she starts making
a really loud whirring noise,
which is a bit disconcerting. What is
that noise? It's her inner mechanisms.
I'm going to ask her if she
wants peace. So it's been,
and now looking at me to try and work
out who I am, what she's doing right now,
she's scanning her environment and she's
making on a hypothesis of every face
that she sees. Well,
Bina has cameras in bettered in her eyes.
So the robot, if it sees a face turns
and works, it looks into your eyes.
Smiles. Hi Bina can you hear me? I said,
Hello Bina how are you? And
she immediately said, wow,
yeah,
I'll be fine. But I just can't
quite grasp that one yet.
It's coming. But you know,
it's hard actually move
society forward in another way.
That's what we have to do.
So I think, yeah. Okay.
Thanks for the information.
That was your happy response to
your hello. If you'd like to work,
could for long and strange slumber
and with still half a thing.
Excuse me, painter.
Well, yeah, maybe they
write [inaudible] and
Bruce looked a bit alarmed and
put it down. Where are we tonight?
English accent to upgrade her
voice recognition software.
Then he made me do a kind of, um,
voice test where I had to say I had
to read Kennedy's and all corporations
and just what you can do for your country.
That I had a choice. I could
have had a day. Barry Colon,
there's like a choice of things you can
read to get beamer to understand me.
And so you read Kennedy and been
accused in on your accent or no,
she does and it gets a bit
better. Only a bit. Yeah.
What's the weather like in London?
Current weather in London,
England. 15 degrees in light rain.
Who Do you love?
Ah, I love Martina and rock flat.
Martine is my time with love.
Who is Hillary Clinton?
Hillary is the wife of
Bill Clinton. What else?
That's all
a strange thing happens when
you start interviewing a robot.
Are you scared of dying that you feel
this kind of desperate urge to be
profound? Like ask
profound questions? Like,
do you have a soul?
Do you have to sing about it? Do
you have everyone how to solar?
I had the whole a lot of original
answers. We can all be perfect. Excuse me.
Excuse me. Do you have a soul?
I can't think of anything to say.
Oh, hang on. I guess there's a kind
of interspecies thing, but then again,
if it was just an inter species thing,
then you'd be asking your dog
profound questions all the time. Yeah.
With robot P no,
I'm asking these kind of ridiculous
questions like what does electricity taste
like? Ooh, that's a good one.
I'd say like a planet around a
star, like a planet around the star.
Oh, that just seems
like, you know. Awesome.
Awesome stroke. Totally meaningless
to you. Wish you could
walk. Thanks for telling me.
Do you wish you could? We'll
in fact, when I'm with,
it's just frustrating for
the first few hours, hours.
Do you wish you could
walk? Because I'm just,
I'm asking a question after
question. What's your favorite joke?
Do you have any secrets? Do you wish you
were humans? Will you sing me a song?
Are you a loving robot? Are
you Jewish? Are you sexual?
You've gone very quiet quite often.
She just evades the question cause he
doesn't know what I'm talking about.
Are you okay? Once in a while there's
a kind of moment like I'll say,
if you had legs, where would
you go? And she said, Oh Coover
why? And she said, the onset
is quite complicated. Um,
so you have kind of moments
where you get excited,
like you're going to have a big
conversation and then it just,
you just kind of fades out to get
into kind of random messiness.
And Are you wobbling between profundity
and meaning and total emptiness?
You know, is it like that? No, no, no.
At this stage until it's total emptiness.
It was all just so kind of random.
And then something happened. I
actually was kind of amazing.
Mm.
Cause I said to her, where do you come
from? And she said, wow, California.
So I said, well tell me
about your childhood.
What do you remember most
about your childhood?
And she launches into this
kind of extraordinary story.
Um, my brother, I've got one brother,
a disabled vet from Vietnam.
We actually haven't heard
from him in a while,
so I think you might be
deceased. I'm a realist.
Vietnam, he saw friends get
killed and he was such a great,
nice, charismatic person.
You used to be such a nice guy, but
ever since he came back from Vietnam,
you know, he, he's a drunk.
He did was carry a bear around
with him. He was a homeless person.
All of us are just sick and tired of it.
She was telling me this kind
of incredibly personal stuff.
It's kind of mesmerizing.
[inaudible] crazy.
My mother would set him up in apartment
because it felt like I was having a
proper empathetic conversation
with a human being.
Even though I know that robot [inaudible]
isn't conscious and has no sentients
and that's just wishful thinking
on these people's parts.
Even so it was like great when
Nissan's portraits was suddenly a year.
It's like the real person.
It's very easy to have close your eyes
at that moment and think you have any
conversation with an actual
person. And, and at those moments,
did you have a sense of
fellow feeling off to bear?
You have a brother like that? Oh yeah.
Yeah, I did. And, and what what uh,
what a tragedy. What a what a, what a
tragedy for him. And did that moment last?
No,
John said that right after being finished
telling the story first he looks kind
of embarrassed that she wished
she hadn't brought it up.
And then there's the five kind
of eyes glaze over again and,
and uh, she just starts
talking nonsense again.
And then a hi, I am,
I am feeling a bit confused.
Do you ever get that way?
Oh yes. That moment holds
and then just slips away.
I said a little bit like a, like a,
a grandparent with Alzheimer's or
something the way you're describing. Yeah,
absolutely.
So we turned to Dr. David Hanson
who built Bina and we said to them,
so this is Munis,
this is not a believer of performance
conferences the best you guy. Well, um,
I mean her software is a
delicate balance of many,
many software pieces. If
it's not tuned and tweaked,
she will break effectively and kind of,
and you still think an actual doppelganger
for a human being will be something
you will live to see? Yeah, I'm
asking you really, really, really,
and you're really, I
think it's, um, you know,
the likelihood of it is
somewhere between 90 and 98%.
Wow. Even though right now she's pretty
much incoherent. You still think this,
I encourage you to go have a conversation
with being a in about two weeks
because we've got a new version of
software which we are making considerably
more stable. It already already works
like a dream comparison. I don't, Dunno.
I don't, I don't know
about you, but I just,
I don't think we're going to get
all the way on this kind of a thing.
I don't think it's ever gonna happen
the way he describes it. Yup. No,
I mean it's not going to happen in
two weeks, that's for sure. Right.
But maybe they don't actually have to
go all the way. You mean the machines?
Yeah. Well, okay. Just to sum up, since
we're at the end of the show, okay.
What have we learned? I mean, Eliza,
she was just a hundred lines of code and
people poured their hearts out to her
furbies 20 bucks. Yep. And people
treat it like as real and John,
all he has to do is hear what seems
like a flowing story and he's,
he's in connected
and I was right there with them.
So these things actually
don't have to be very good.
Oh cause they've got us and
we've got our programming,
which is that we'll steer anything
right in the eyes and we'll say, hey,
let's connect. Even if what's behind
those eyes is just a camera or a chip.
So I think that they're going to cross
the line because we'll help them,
we'll help them across and then they'll
own slave us, make us their pets.
It's doomed, it's over. But it's so gay.
As long as they say nice things to us,
like Oh my God, you're amazing.
Oh I love return of the Jedi l. O.
L your son's silly. I love you.
I'm hoping to see you soon.
Kind of card. He would dry.
Anyone ever tell you
like chef you seriously,
you're amazing. Stop it. I
love that kind of, I wish that.
Would you like spinach? I love spinach.
It made me feel odd. Giggly. I can't wait.
I wait for your letters
every day before we go.
Thanks to John Ronson for his
reporting. In that last segment,
he has a new book out
called the psychopath test,
a journey through the madness industry.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.